all right so Loki season two is gonna
play a huge role as the glue in the
upcoming multiversal King Dynasty coming
off the heels of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania but aside from a few casting
announcements and only our imagination
we know virtually nothing of this
international Man of mischief's second
season luckily some Brave fans from d23
and various cons have risked being
sniped by old Kevin himself and leaked a
trailer that gives fans of Loki even
more reason to ship Loki and Mobius or
rather lokius in his upcoming season 2.
so in this video I want to go over the
new leaks behind the scenes pictures new
Scoops and even some crazy theories as
to what season two of Loki will have in
store for us but yeah thank you for
clicking this I'm your resident TVA
agent Jared now let's get into some
leaks for Loki season two now if you
remember at the end of season one Loki
appears to have been transported to an
entire entirely different version of the
TVA here Mobius and Hunter B15 do not
remember Loki at all with him soon
finding out that Kang or he who remains
has conquered this timeline and is in
control of the TVA hence the giant
statue of my man however what we see in
this trailer that Paul's Uncle who works
at Marvel showed to us yeah good guy
really works at Marvel is a bit
misleading actually also we did a full
breakdown for this leaked trailer a
couple weeks ago you can click it right
up here but these leaks help us
understand a bit more so shout out to
Daniel rpk for dropping several of these
leaks on his patreon but the trailer
paints Loki as this man out of time and
sort of teleports to different places as
if someone is either fast forward or
rewinding him in time with one of those
temp pads however this isn't the work of
a temp pad or Kang but rather he is
stuck in a cycle of going to the Future
Past present because of Sylvie pruning
him out of time and it's revealed the
reason that Mobius and B15 don't
recognize him is because this is before
he ever showed up at the TVA so instead
of this being a completely different
multiversal version of the TVA
completely different people one where
Kang ruled it's the same one we saw in
season one only set years and years
before yeah it's a bit strange like Loki
says in the trailer but at the beginning
of the TVA Kang decided to be front and
center he was a public figure but once
he learned of the dealings his variants
were up to he stepped down as the Public
Image erased all of the minds of the TVA
members so therefore there is no
knowledge of his presence instead
creating the idea of the three time
Keepers as a Wizard of Oz approach to
hide who was actually behind everything
and hiding himself from his variants so
this is why there is a giant statue of
Kang at the end of season one because
this is actually really the past and
later in most of you know Loki season
one The timekeepers are the ones to be
feared because the TVA knows nothing of
Kang but with Loki shifting time era so
much it's an awful game of telephone
trying to fill in the past and present
hell even maybe even the future with
missing information each group needs
this further explains the shot from the
trailer of Loki using a Time stick on
the wall featuring the timekeepers only
to reveal Engravings of Kang hidden
underneath this shot is the present
timeline from Loki season 1 because we
also see a severed time keeper head on
the table as Loki makes this reveal good
on you [ __ ] trying to throw us off your
scent but this reveal of it all being
the same universe is discovered like in
episode 1 which feels like a less than
satisfying Cliffhanger for season 1 to
have actually ended on still cool that
Loki is trapped out of time which has
got to be one hell of a headache now in
order to stop this time jumping no
Loki's not gonna watch the hit 2002 time
stopping movie clock stoppers for help
instead Mobius takes him to visit Q hu
Kwan's character of Euro Boris just just
call him time Timmy or something what's
with these names anyway this is an
original character created for the
series but also goes by the nickname of
Beau he's described as a TVA archivist
like the Q of the TVA you know Q from
the bond franchise in charge of research
and Technology new gadgets for bond to
use and break in the field so Beau or
maybe it's Bo I mean that'd be a stinky
name holds this position at the TVA and
helps develop a device for Loki that
prevents the time jumps flat out or
rather controls them so he can return to
the present a personalized time door for
Loki if you will it's cool we'll see
Quan in another multiversal weird
property after everything everywhere all
at once and hopefully he's featured in a
decent amount of this series now the
main plot of season 2 might be less
intriguing than you have hoped Kang is
unfortunately not going to be the big
bad the main villain of season two
instead taking a secondary role more
background probably playing into the
past storyline more than the present one
that we saw in season one instead Daniel
rpk reports that Kate Dickey is playing
a main role in season 2 and is said to
be the villain of this series the leaks
continue hinting that she will be
playing an older version of Sylvie who
has actually teamed up with several
Rogue TVA agents to help right the
wrongs of season one however her
identity this reveal will not be shown
until later in the season keeping the
mystery of who she actually is for a
late season reveal it goes on implying
that Dickie's character and the Rogue
TVA agents are purging the new timelines
that were created when he who remains
died at the end of season 1. a villain
Arc based on regret isn't something new
but it will be interesting when an old
and young versions of the same character
meet one another like if this happened
to me I'd tell myself to go buy some
Dogecoin to the Moon baby but with older
Sylvia on this villain Redemption Arc
Loki Mobius and the TVA are said to be
the ones trying to stop her they do this
to prevent any unnecessary deaths that
they want and the timelines to be free
which is kind of a switch up from season
one it's also said that the other Loki
is from season 1 will return meaning
that crocky locky I'm gonna call him
that will be there to help out the only
Loki that will not return unfortunately
is classic Loki due to how it ended in
season one however the person that they
truly need to help them fight this older
Sylvie is the Sylvie that's the younger
Sylvie from season one yeah this is
gonna be a variant filled finger
pointing at everyone type of season
however they don't know where Sylvie
actually is hiding out or rather win
like what time through a series of
events they discover that she's hiding
out in
1970s essentially living a normal life
working at McDonald's her wanting a
normal life ties into how she never
really got a normal life because of the
TBA and wants to serve up some tasty
Burgers behind the scenes photos confirm
this with a McDonald's restaurant and
Sylvie wearing what appears to be a
McDonald's uniform that was commonplace
in this time area I'm gonna get real
sweaty right now but this has got to be
the late 70s not the early 70s because
if we zoom into the McDonald's menu
chicken McNuggets are featured and I am
a chicken nugget fiend and I know that
they were only available in select
restaurants in the late 70s so it looks
like it might be a little bit closer to
the 80s like I said late 70s but it does
look like Sylvie is definitely loving it
but the group wants to pull her out of
her normal life to help with older
Sylvie also the Romantic tension
relationship is said to be still
happening between Loki and Sylvie giving
the expression go [ __ ] yourself in
entirely different meaning oh and you
know what else was invented in the 70s
jet skis baby well the first stand-up
one I don't care how or what or what we
gotta do but Mobius is gonna be on that
jet ski I'm telling you feige do it you
cowards do it as for other pieces of the
trailer it appears multiple Loki's
Mobius and B15 dress up to attend some
sort of movie premiere who why what my
best guess is some sort of heist and I
think it's to gain information from a
completely obscure Marvel villain zaniac
I'm not gonna bore you with this dude's
comic Origins but the evil entity
essentially possessed a working actor
Brad wolf and surprisingly enough there
are movie posters for a premiere of a
movie called zaniac starring Brad wolf
seen in behind the scenes photos my
working theory is that Brad wolf is
being played by Raphael Casal who was
cast in an unknown role and seen on at
working with both Loki and Mobius one of
Brad wolf or zaniac's characteristics is
an overwhelming bloodlust or desire to
kill women so the group goes to the
movie premiere kidnap zaniac and uses
him as some sort of tracking dog like a
bloodhound oh
bloodlust Bloodhound he's a good tracker
this is far too on the nose but
essentially they use him to track down
Sylvie in the 70s another theory is that
Loki due to the time jumps has seen the
future and the start or even the ending
of Secret Wars there are a couple lines
of dialogue stating there's nothing that
stands between this world and utter
destruction and that war is on the way
war secret Wars and there's a shot of a
futuristic white lab or Command Center
that doesn't look like it belongs in the
TVA so this could be Kang's Command
Center overlooking the events of Secret
Wars this is why Loki is bent out of
shape he has seen the end of everything
which could be one of the few times Kang
makes an appearance as the villain
there's also a rumor of Loki returning
back to the 616 Universe at the end of
the series which I find hard to believe
but if so it could be another Gamora
situation with him out there and about
maybe Loki even dies at the end and ends
up in Valhalla which is why it was
teased at the end of Thor love and
thunder I don't know I'm getting way off
the rails but it could happen maybe a
little messy but maybe lastly Loki's
season to adjacent is some Deadpool 3
news with Daniel rpk reporting that
Mobius and the TVA are to play a main
role in this story wow yes Owen Wilson
is said to be reprising his role and
gives us some hints as to what Deadpool
and Wolverine will be up to it has been
clear that this version of Wolverine
that we'll be getting in this movie is a
different multiversal version than the
one that was in Logan so hit F to pay
respects because that Bubby dead no red
cons here this means that Mobius may be
the one to guide Deadpool and Wolverine
through their epic buddy road trip
through the entire MCU the TVA could be
the ones that are going after the pair
to prune them as they are seen to kind
of be a threat to Kang if we get
Deadpool Wolverine and Mobius crew
cruising on some sea Doos Kang and the
TVA have got to defuse the whole
situation there have even been some
Twitter interactions between The Miz
minutes account and Ryan Reynolds so
it's only a matter of time wow as for
when we might see Loki season 2 kind of
depends on a few things with it being
said to be released in summer 2023 and
we're kind of factoring in the MCU
theatrical releases I believe sometime
around Memorial Day here in the states
might be the best window of opportunity
Guardians volume 3 hits theaters the
first week of May while the Marvel's
release is the final weekend of July
2023 popping Loki into this window feels
like the right choice even starting the
first week of June would be perfect
mirroring the release of season one the
only hiccup is the echo series is
supposed to release in summer 2023 as
well depending if this even happens
honestly it's just a toss-up right now
which one will come first so beginning
of June or mid August but obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on these
leaks and speculation for Loki season 2
is this going to play a pivotal role
into the Kang Dynasty and when do you
think season 2 will be dropping on
Disney Plus and I'll let you know we're
currently running competition right now
giving away three copies of House of
dragons season one on the 15th of
December and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment Down Below on Loki
season 2. we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of last month are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other cool videos click
one or we'll prune you with that out of
the way thanks for watching I've been
Jared the Mobius of heavy spoilers and
I'm off to check out a rad Sea-Doo we'll
see in the next one take care and peace